in today's Digital World cloud computing
has become a crucial aspect of
technology and business operations it
enables organizations to store process
and manage large amounts of data and
applications over the internet and hence
the demand for people with cloud
computing skills is growing rapidly with
a 23.1 percent year-over-year increase
with an average annual salary of one
hundred and thirty thousand dollars not
only that the projected cagr of cloud
computing between 2021 and 2028 is 19.1
percent this growth demonstrates the
growing demand for cloud computing
Professionals in both developed and
Emerging Markets so if you're ready to
take a deep dive into the world of cloud
computing this boot camp is a great
place to begin the Caltech cloud
computing bootcamp helps you become an
expert in Azure and AWS this in-depth
boot camp course lets you master key
Cloud architectural principles needed to
become a cloud expert according to a
survey 9 out of 10 of our Learners
achieve their learning objectives after
successful course completion this cloud
computing bootcamp helps you become an
expert in designing planning and scaling
cloud implementations and will also help
you master the core skill sets required
to deploy dynamically scalable and
reliable applications on Microsoft Azure
and AWS this boot camp will cover AWS
Cloud fundamentals this module will
introduce you to the fundamentals of the
Amazon web services or AWS Cloud
platform and ensure that you are fully
proficient in identifying AWS
terminologies Concepts and benefits next
up we have designing applications and
architectures in AWS in this module you
will learn to identify services and
features to build resilient secure and
highly available it Solutions in the AWS
Cloud the next course covered in this
master's program is azure Cloud
fundamentals this module will provide
foundational level knowledge of azure
Concepts Azure Services solution and
management tools General Security and
network security governance and
compliance features Azure cost
management and service level agreements
coming to the next module Implement
manage and monitor on Azure environment
in this course you will learn how to
manage Azure subscriptions secure
identities and Minister the
infrastructure configure virtual
networking connect Azure and on-premises
sites manage Network traffic Implement
Storage Solutions and more next we have
design infrastructure Solutions on Azure
in this module you will learn how to
design infrastructure Solutions we will
cover topics such as governance compute
application architecture storage data
integration authentication networks
business continuity and migrations and
the final one is the cloud computing
Capstone project this cloud computing
Capstone project will give you an
opportunity to implement the skills you
learned throughout this cloud computing
boot camp through dedicated mentoring
sessions you'll learn how to solve a
real-world industry aligned Cloud
problem along with these there will be a
cloud computing bootcamp master class in
which the experts will respond to your
concerns so what else can you expect
from this program this program includes
live learning with Hands-On exercises
and access to Caltech ctme instructor
Caltech Circle membership and quarterly
campus engagement earn a cloud computing
boot camp certificate and up to 15 CEUs
credits from Caltech ctme one-to-one
mentoring and resume writing access to 3
million plus jobs via our network of 15
000 plus recruiters Caltech cloud
computing boot camp is the first and the
only boot camp in the industry which
provides 40 plus Hands-On projects with
integrated Labs 25 plus tools and cloud
services dedicated support and
mentorship Capstone project in four
domains Career Services support
sandboxed Cloud Labs the online training
will help you with various skills like
multi-cloud deployment performance
testing database management web services
and API Cloud workloads Auto scaling and
many more you'll also get hands-on
experience with tools like AWS Lambda
Azure container service Amazon ec2
Amazon dynamodb Azure resource manager
Etc the program is based on an applied
learning approach that uses the
combination of self-paced videos upon
completion of this program you will
receive the Caltech ctme bootcamp
certificate you will also receive
certificates from Simply learn for each
of the courses in the learning path
these certificates will testify to your
skills as an expert in Cloud so what are
you waiting for don't miss out on this
chance to take your career to the next
level enroll in our Caltech cloud
computing boot camp today and start your
journey to become a cloud computing
expert the link is added in the
description box and the comments section
below
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here